hi Han how are you so nice to be here
good I'm excited to have this
opportunity to visit with you about this
new book called drink it was very
intriguing and very provocative and like
I said reminded me of when I was working
in treatment about the relationship
about alcohol and women I guess one of
the questions that I wanted to ask you
right off is like why now you know why
is the subject seen as a crisis and
important for you to get the message out
we are seeing a global problem a closing
of the gender gap between men and women
traditionally we've always known that
men drink more than women do but what's
been happening recently is men have been
declining a little bit in their risky
drinking women are not at all and this
is global the more developed the country
the richer the country the smaller the
gap between men and women's consumption
places like Britain for instance where
we're almost seeing parity where we're
seeing young girls in their 20s who are
dying of an stage liver disease which is
classically seen as an old man disease
so this is a health epidemic crisis
something that we need to pay attention
to and open up the dialogue about our
favorite drug because it is our favorite
drug that's legal and most of us consume
that's correct that's very theft exactly
can you talk maybe a bit about the
driving force for you in writing drink
the driving force for me is decades old
I grew up with an alcoholic mother who
was cross addicted to valium much like a
lot of women were and in the 60s and the
70s dependent on mother's little helper
and she was a stay-at-home mom really
was a poster girl for that era I have
always been interested in why she drank
the way she drank and the one thing I
said to myself as I never will and in
fact in my 50s I fell into really bad
behavior with alcohol I had a bad patch
in my own life and I
I would say poster girl for this era I'm
well educated highly professional woman
mother and found myself drinking not two
glasses of wine not three glasses of
wine but four and five and six a night I
slipped into some bad behavior caught
myself quickly and went to rehab so in
that what was that like for you
that realization if you can maybe talk
about that right it was probably the
worst thing I've ever gone through in
the sense that I was full of shame I was
full of I was deeply humiliated by my
behavior I didn't miss work I didn't
crack cars up I didn't do any of the
above but I did black out I did black
homecoming for each night before I went
to sleep and it was something that I
said well I'll get a handle on it I had
a cousin a favorite cousin who was
killed by a drunk driver and I thought
I've lost so much to alcohol my
childhood now my cousin Doug I'll just
quit and I couldn't and I knew I was
addicted and I found myself going for
help but it was confounding was
confounding and also my behavior didn't
look like my mother's so I thought I
can't possibly be alcohol okay okay
there's a adage that I learned as a kid
is kind of like mirror mirror on the
wall I am my mother after all all right
all right
do you think that what you've
experienced is pretty common with other
women I know that the behavior or the
extreme behavior that I was involved in
is at the far end of the spectrum in
that I became addicted I think a lot of
women the the larger group of women are
not addicted it's only about two and a
half percent depending on the country
how many are actually alcoholic but
there are a lot of women involved in
really risky behavior binge drinking the
Centers for Disease Control came out in
January and warned about the fact that
this was at epidemic proportions and
that's the thing we don't focus on
anti-culture we focus
the alcoholic or the drunk driver we
don't look at the common person's
behavior and for a woman it's only nine
drinks a week in terms of low-risk
drinking guidelines and that's not a lot
and never more than two on one occasion
that means taking nights off from
drinking and a lot of people would find
that something that they couldn't manage
what about for young girls it does it
kind of do they fall in the same range
as that because I know that when you
look at the age differences between you
know young women and say women our age
you know finding you know the difficulty
are there differences amongst the age
you know group for women in general
right the young generation of women has
been targeted very heavily by the
alcohol industry and by that I mean in
about the night mid 1990s there was we
saw the invention of alcopops those
sweet vodka infused prepackaged drinks
that are basically starter drinks
cocktails with training wheels
transitional drinks to get people
interested in drinking move them away
from beer because young women usually
don't like the taste of beer and what
happens is they mature into vodka
drinkers so on campuses you've got young
men and young women playing drinking
games but the young guys playing it with
beer and she who might be two-thirds his
body size is playing it with vodka or
shots very risky behavior and we all
know that alcohol is the number one date
rape drug so we're seeing a very
different behavior on the part of this
generation doesn't drink and drive but
they pre drink before they go out to a
bar because it's expensive they have
alcohol in their dorms they have alcohol
they
they drink ahead of the event which
means once they get to the event they're
often already inebriated it's very risky
behavior that also puts them at risk for
what other types of behaviors many other
types of behaviors risk we you see high
profile accent
Falls certainly sexual behavior that
maybe wasn't wanted absolutely a broad
spectrum of accidents and and and so on
and so forth but what's fascinating
right now is that young women used to
slow down after University College
they'd slow down young men didn't always
but young women did they're not doing
that now why do you think that is I
think that women are getting a very
complex message I think we're in the
middle of a sociological revolution
young women are told that they have to
have a great career they have to be
great mothers they have to be thin they
have to be good-looking they have to
manage a house well and there is a sense
of entitlement I can do everything that
a young man does that includes having a
glass of wine or two after work want
drinking - lying down and women tend to
medicate depression and anxiety and
loneliness I think there's a lot of
anxiety in this generation in terms of
how do I manage it all and so when we
look at who is drinking the most we're
seeing the professional woman the
educated woman and I don't think this is
what Gloria Steinem had in mind when she
talked about being equal that sounds as
though that the expectations that not
only society puts on women but what we
take on ourselves as well too plays a
role in right the changing right I beg
the question in the book of whether it's
the modern woman's steroid enabling her
when I drank I drank to stay awake I
drank to sleep I drink to relax at a
party I used it I used alcohol I think I
think if you are relaxing rewarding
yourself as it can be fine but if you're
numbing yourself not a great idea
as I was reading through drink one of
the things that came to mind for me were
there times when you found yourself kind
of hesitating to move forward in writing
and putting words on paper about your
experience yes this was a huge decision
this book wrote in some part in some
ways from a huge series that I did in
Canada's largest newspaper it was a
series fourteen part series on women and
alcohol and at the time my editors said
to me how do you feel about telling your
own story she knew that I had a history
with alcohol abuse and I said I'm
beginning to think maybe I should tell
it and she said you have to work again
and I said yes and she said then you
can't this stigma is too great I really
paused for about two years before I
decided to write this drink and it was
drinking this book it was a huge
decision once I made the decision once I
put pen to paper it came out with me
very quickly but I was worried about how
I would be seen you know there's there's
the same that we have public lives we
have private lives and we have secret
lives and it was a relief to tell the
secret okay yeah because as they say
secrets keep you sick secrets do keep
you safe and I found this incredibly
cathartic and a terrific relief to have
this okay good very good
how do you see the path of women's
drinking patterns different from men
yeah there's a lot of research that when
a man gets into trouble with alcohol he
tends to go to the bar the pub hangs out
with his friends and then makes new
friends maybe not great friends and
that's the pattern a woman tends to
drink alone to isolate to numb
complicated feelings around depression
as I did and anxiety that's a female
model and so when a woman goes to
treatment it's really important we now
know for her to have a hard look at the
things that were triggers for her the
the war triggers it can be really hard
when you get sober as I did and find
that the things that you were numbing or
trying to numb depression all of a
sudden is I'm medicated so it's really
important when you go to treatment or
are dealing with sobriety new sobriety
that you recognize that you're going to
have a whole host of emotions that you
have to address unmedicated or medicated
in a different way and this is this is
progress because they used to believe
that when you went to treatment you had
to be sober for two years before you
dealt with the underlying causes now for
women in treatment it's very difficult
because getting to treatment is the
issue getting to treatment especially if
you have young children babies we see
some fabulous entities across North
America that appreciate what young
mothers have to deal with when they're
trying to get sober but they're feel far
few and far between and too often it
depends on who you know whether you have
enough money where you live whether
you'll get the right kind of treatment
why do you think that is oh I think it's
obvious I think our our values as a
society around alcohol are very fuzzy I
don't think we've we've decided what we
want to do we all think if I'm
sophisticated I know my wines if I'm an
adult I should know how to handle my
liquor if I'm drinking a little too much
maybe I'm just trying to act like the
French or the Spanish or the Italian it
isn't me that has a problem it's that
rare drinking driver we don't look at
ourselves because we don't want to this
is something we use to relax we love
alcohol as a culture it's cheap in our
culture very very cheap sometimes in a
corner store or gas station is cheaper
than milk and cheaper than orange juice
so we have fussy values and I think we
haven't really done well on mental
health we've done well in understanding
depression we haven't done well at all
on understanding addiction okay yeah
okay you know another question that as I
was reading
your book is that kind of your thoughts
support groups such as AAA versus women
of sobriety and whether or not if you
think that there are some differences
between support groups that are geared
mainly towards men as opposed to those
geared towards women great question
women for sobriety is a group that
developed some time ago and I really
admire it it really focuses was a
reaction in part against the word
powerlessness which is an a a term and
women were having trouble with with some
of the language of the big book of AAA
the problem with women for sobriety is
that it is very hard if you are live in
a small town or even in where I live in
a big city to find women for sobriety
group you can start your own but it's
difficult I think it's interesting that
the face of AAA has really changed face
of AAA has become much more female and
much younger and in the younger
generation there's huge pride in being
sober there's a lot of shame in my
generation stigma but the younger
generation is pretty proud of rocking
sobriety do you think that that's
interesting that you say that do you
think that the the overall public views
it or sees that same concept as young
individuals in AAA
no I think it's totally hidden I think
the anonymity piece has made sure it's
then kept hidden and I'm a big fan of
something called faces and voices of
recovery based in Washington very very
strong organization and I'm part of a
movement in Canada just establishing now
faces and voices of recovery Canada and
the idea of being we tell our stories I
tell people that I am five years without
wine five years without a drink I lead a
terrific life I don't need to break my
anonymity
and tell you how I keep sober but I need
to tell you that I'm sober and this is
what it looks like I'm in recovery great
that's great are you familiar with the
concept of recovery oriented systems of
care not I'm not and so and that's it's
a philosophy that was pretty much coined
by William white oh yes in taking a look
at how to build a community you know
community of recovery you know and I was
just kind of wondering as I you know in
your book reading about AAA and then I
was thinking about the women you know
the differences for women I remember
while working in a treatment facility
that a lot of times women they did not
they may go initially but then they
would fall out you know because the the
the relationship piece right now that
women generally have to deal with or not
generally but have to deal with as they
move into a covery
and I was just also wondering whether or
not if you were familiar with the the
recovery oriented systems of care
concepts as well too and so you know
that's so funny that just came across my
radar this week I'm William white and I
don't know if you've seen the film on
the anonymous people yes fabulous yes
and that was that was the trigger for me
do you understand who he was yes yeah
yes yeah good that's good
I wonder if you could maybe talk a
little bit about what you see as as it
relates to are there differences in
isolation for women we know that there
are differences in isolation for women
when they're actively drinking right
what about when they get into recovery
are there similarities with the whole
issue of isolation for women as they
move into recovery I think in recovery
you have to be really careful of
isolation you have to be really careful
about your self-care I think for women
and and that's why I'm such a fan of
women for a sobriety is that there's a
focus on the self-care piece there's a
focus on
respecting yourself and looking after
yourself and I think that I can't speak
for being a man in recovery but I know
that when I'm involved with my friends
who are also sober this is something we
focus on a lot making sure that you
don't get too lonely too hungry to angry
too lonely you're tired Holt is very
important and what I found in new
sobriety was everything was new
everything was you know it wasn't just
the fact I've never been through a
Christmas or New Year's or birthday
sober but absolutely everything in terms
of my human relationship so I live much
more consciously and I live much more
happily now I know that one of the
things that you refer to is about
drinking by women is a cultural thing
and and I'm wondered if maybe you could
speak a little bit about what do you
mean by that
the phenomenon of women drinking is I
think very much a piece of entitlement
our sense of entitlement we can we can't
we're allowed to we don't never heard it
put like that any floor what we should
be able to because men can so we can and
certainly the younger generation has
that feeling but going toe to toe with
men is actually really a dangerous thing
15 percent of breast cancer cases are
related to alcohol met democratically
were equal but metabolically and
hormonal II we aren't it's true and when
it comes to alcohol and what I really
find is is alcohol the new tobacco no
but is is the alcohol industry behaving
like the tobacco industry used to yes
this is Virginia Slims in a bottle
focused on women we have a feminized
drinking culture with wines like mummy
juice and girls night out wines and
Skinnygirl vodka and happy [ __ ] wine
believe it or not and this is focused a
totally feminized drinking culture did
it all start with
Carrie Bradshaw when she was drinking
those Cosmopolitan's on Sex in the City
no didn't did she add to it yes she did
but we have a female drinking culture
now and it's I think I'm coming upon us
to make sure that young people young
women are market savvy they understand
and being targeted they understand that
the alcohol product has become a person
it's tweeting it's on Facebook it's
trying to get you as part of the
community if Smirnoff or whatever the
alcohol is and you're the target and
that is like the tobacco industry I
thought when I read that in your book I
thought you know to shade because after
I really thought about it there is a
strong analogy between the two right and
into which along with that having been
you know attended a tobacco conference
and one of the sessions I remember
attending was they were you know I had
to do with the marketing strategy and
how they really earmarked and really
focused on certain groups of people and
I can you know based off of what you're
saying I see the same thing for women as
well too with the alcohol industry
really targeting in on women but not
only targeting in on women but do you
see them targeting in on more of a
specific racial ethnic groups as well -
you do see a huge vulnerability if you
look at the data coming out of colleges
that certain ethnic groups are actually
drinking at a higher rate than others
and so when you look at the up swinging
in young women you see that women from
different races having more trouble it's
a complex story
it's very about number one predictor of
whether you'll get into trouble as a
woman with alcohol is childhood sexual
abuse that is your number one predictor
more than jeans more than anything else
it is very much related to trauma and
therefore trauma related
rehab and treatment is really important
we've seen a wonderful upswing and the
understanding that trauma does relate to
alcohol abuse this is our easiest and
most accessible drug and people do
medicate with it and women do all the
time yeah yeah at one point in time it
used to be the mindset for treatment
providers is to not even address that
right but now that has shifted which I'm
glad to see is to address that but what
is the the risk of women being come to
become reach Ramat eyes you know if
they're in treatment and they're talking
about the trauma that they have
experienced it's really an important
question because you have to be very
very savvy as a treatment provider to
make sure that you don't reach Ramat
eyes a person I for instance went to
rehab and was diagnosed with PTSD
post-traumatic stress syndrome and I had
to really take my time with the trauma
that I was dealing with and to take my
time and know that this was a multi-year
issue that I had to address that I
couldn't do it overnight you don't want
to reach Ramat eyes a person but
speaking of retraumatization one of the
problems is young women will have a
trauma in their life drink too much find
themselves in a compromising position
sexually and beer eat raw meat I women
have to keep themselves safe there's a
real connection with as I said day rape
with abuse with violence being the
victim of partner violence it puts one
in a really vulnerable place to have too
much to drink
so there's many reasons to be cognizant
of what you're putting down you're going
hmm
exactly maybe moving on can you speak to
and you you alluded to it a little bit
before when you started out you know
that you starting the faces and voices
every cover
in Canada about the role of stigma and
addressing it and why that's so
important and if there are if you think
that there are differences gender
differences in how the role of stigma is
addressed yes yes I think that you can
be male in our culture and have too much
to drink and be seen as a good old guy
you're a bon vivant you are just a
terrific guy yeah a woman you don't you
lose your masculinity a woman drinks too
much and she is seen as sloppy she's not
seen as feminine we're much harder on
women who drink too much and so I think
in faces and voices of recovery Canada
and in the States we're very much
following the parent organization in the
United States the notion is we've known
for more than twenty years that
addiction is a disease it's a complex
disease like diabetes you have to
contribute to it yourself but it is a
disease we've known that but we don't as
a culture see it that way we see it as a
moral failing we see definitely a mother
who drinks as way down the totem pole in
terms of one you could respect or admire
and then we get into the very complex
issue of pregnant women drinking so
there is a pecking order and stigma is
enormous for women it's something that
we have to have a more open dialogue
about and people in recovery who have as
I do five years clean and sober others
with 10 and 15 and 20 have to stand up
and be counted we have to shift we pay
so much attention as a person who spent
30 years in the media we pay so much
attention to a person like Charlie Sheen
when it gets into trouble on xo2 Robert
Downey jr. when you're Whitney Houston
but when they get clean and sober we
don't focus very much on them we are not
as interested when the antics of stop
Lindsay Lohan we just were just
fascinated by by the misbehave
here and as I say it's very much like
the issue with mental health we need to
profoundly understand what's going wrong
we live in an alkyl genic society we
need to pay more attention to this fact
yeah do you think that it is that
society thrives off the chaos and chaos
in other individuals lives oh sure
there's a vicarious interest and
watching somebody else destruct
self-destruct there's no doubt about it
and that's compelling but it's tragic
and it's we have to have a lot more
compassion I don't know that we're a
compassionate society in terms of
appreciating we can't appreciate the
person who was born with depression or
suffers from diabetes but we are not
very sympathetic or empathetic when
someone has an addiction issue from your
perspective what would be a
comprehensive public health response to
this issue well there's there's no doubt
in my mind that pricing is a huge issue
we if you look at the hard data on the
cost of alcohol it has just become
cheaper and cheaper and cheaper Oh in
recent years and as I was saying earlier
often in a gas station I would argue why
is it even in the gas station but often
in the gas station it's cheaper than the
milk or the orange juice and that's just
wrong there's very clear data that says
that if you added a 10% increase to that
cost that you would see a nine percent
drop in terms of hospital admit
emissions for emergencies for instance
around alcohol the cost is just too
accessible that's overly accessible it's
overly cheap and we're not connecting
the dots with a lot of trouble what
we're doing for instance in Canada is
certain in certain regions as we're
starting to produce report cards so we
know that alcohol produces a lot
of tax revenue for the government but
what we're doing is connecting the dots
on those emergency room admissions the
policing related to alcohol so that we
can understand that it's costly
yes hugely costly I think we should take
a very hard look at marketing I don't
think that there should be the marketing
allowed that there is especially in
social media which is targeting youth
mm-hmm I think that is is definitely
wrong and I think we should see alcopops
which are targeted to the teenage
drinker the young drinker those alcopops
those pre-mixed drinks should definitely
not be categorized as they are in the
United States as malt beverages so that
they can be sold like beer and sold
cheaply it's just wrong what are the
things would you do you think needs to
be included in that public health
strategies I guess you know looking at
what other type of strategies would be
we need to take a hard look at treatment
we need to take a hard look at a
comprehensive reinvestment in treatment
so then it's not just for the rich and
famous that it's you know for instance
I'll give you an example I was at Betty
Ford in the last six months and they're
lamenting the fact that a lot of the
programs that were aimed at children
children of addicted parents have gone
the way of the dodo bird when we've seen
health care cuts so helping children and
and get a getting away from that second
generational problem is something that I
think should be very hard high on the
totem pole of needs and importance so
we're not really understanding how if we
don't understand what the diseases we
certainly don't understand that it's not
one of those things that you come in and
get fixed for in 30 days and then you
walk away and you're fine if you have
breast cancer or cancer you're told
where your aftercare is like you go in
for a 30-day program and I've been there
and I did come to this states you're
essentially seen as fine when you leave
follow up his key taking care of
yourself is
so I don't think we have a full
understanding of what needs to be done
when this product is so cheap so
accessible tact so badly in the United
States tax terribly and privatized and
we have a real problem mm-hmm so it's
like really getting to a place where
there's parity between this particular
disease as well as other diseases such
as breast cancer
absolutely mm-hmm exactly I think you
touched on this before but if there's
anything else you want to talk about the
similarities with tobacco policy and
what similar strategies could be
mirrored related to risky drinking
behavior one of the things that has come
up recently is an appreciation in the
past five years of some of the 50
diseases and cancers that are related to
to alcohol we have not had a public
dialogue about that we don't appreciate
at all that there are some downsides to
drinking we have typically thought
there's drinking and driving and there's
liver cirrhosis and other than that we
don't appreciate that all the throat
cancers the colorectal cancers that are
related to drinking we don't appreciate
here's a big one the people die epically
20 years younger than they do with
smoking mm-hmm that's a huge one and
women die faster than men from from
drinking so we're not having a public
health conversation the way we
jump-started one on tobacco years ago
that's really we know the problems with
trans fats we know the problems with
tanning beds and and not with this it
doesn't make any sense we know more
about gluten and we know about alcohol
and anise or want to know maybe our want
to know or want very good point so I
think that that is the key issue and I
think just like with tobacco if you keep
it simple if you keep it to
accessibility and price
you will be able to turn around the big
levers you can turn around many of the
problems that are major issues
so you see Washington State for instance
and privatizing and putting putting
alcohol and Costco's and the huge
complexity of what's unfolding in that
state you see what's interesting in in
the United States has many petri dish
experiments in terms of you know what
what policy changes come about and how
that affects people thank you know
there's there's no doubt that u.s. the
United States is ripe you have countries
like Scotland that is are looking at
minimum pricing which is fabulous
Britain should have Britain should have
and decided not to you look at South
Africa which is looking at a marketing
ban fabulous because they have such a
huge problem with fetal alcohol syndrome
so people and that is a whole other
subject feel alcohol spectrum disorder
actually so there many policy whizzes in
this country some of the best research
in the world but the gap between what we
know and what we don't do is enormous
mm-hmm would you say it's more so here
than it is in other countries absolutely
more so no alcohol is hugely cheap in
this country I mean in Canada we have
monopolies liquor monopolies and a
fairly firm hand on on pricing but here
all bets are off
all gloves are off and I come regularly
to an alcohol policy conference here
called AP whatever years a terrific
conference and and global but in North
America we have some of the best brains
working on these issues and yet the
public's the public's appetite for
understanding this is small so it sounds
like I hear you saying that there's a
great deal of environmental strategies
that could be utilized but maybe you're
not necessarily capitalized on exact
okay okay what sort of messages can be
incorporated across the lifespan for
females that could reach them about the
impact of risky drinking well I think in
Canada we had lowers drinking guidelines
come out in 2011 and with that nine
drinks per week there was a lot of
pushback in the women I know there's a
lot of pushback saying nine drinks a
week are you kidding me
what if I have four or five on a
Saturday night and four or five on a
Friday night
I'm already over my you know over my
limit so I think we're in the middle of
an educational uptick where we have to
just start to have the conversation
start to know what is safe but you see
for instance in a big study out of
Harvard recently a huge problem with how
much young women are binge drinking at
the college campus level versus how much
young man are drinking that old frat boy
stereotype is out the window John
Belushi if he was alive today would be
female yeah okay okay I noticed that I
would had was reading your bio online
and one of the things think we've got a
few minutes left but one of the things I
wanted to ask you about the National
roundtable on girls women in alcohol to
provide you an opportunity maybe kind of
talk about that effort the purpose of it
and kind of where what's your vision for
it our vision is to open the dialogue
about those policy levers that you and I
were just talking about about what does
marketing look like what does good
marketing awareness look like how do you
get that into the schools how do you
reach fifteen-year-old girls who are the
just facing a lot of social media and
educate them that they have been
targeted how do you do that how do you
look at accessibility so we're trying to
build awareness we're trying to be build
policy understand
in Canada on the issue of girls and
women on the understanding that girls
women are far more vulnerable towards
alcohol abuse and men are so that
initiative visits I like to tell a
little story it's a short one there's a
frog pond and a lot of the frogs are
sterile and a lot of frogs are growing
warts do you send me and the surgeons
and the fertility experts or do you say
maybe there's something in the water the
national roundtable basically is saying
there's something in the water our
culture has got it wrong let's open up a
dialogue and get it right so with that
in the face of the voices of recovery
I'm pretty busy
wonderful wonderful we've got maybe just
a few minutes left and I wonder if
there's anything else that you would
like to to say about this issue about
your book which I love the title of the
intimate relationship between women and
alcohol because that's what it is
it is a relationship whether we like it
or not but you know yes it's it's an
enormous it's what I like to say is I
don't mean to be a killjoy I have
certainly enjoyed my fair share of
alcohol in my life but one of the things
that really alarmed me other than the
young the data about young women really
alarmed me was the fact that the more
professional more educated you were the
more likely you're going to get into
trouble with alcohol in fact your one
protective thing would be a blue-collar
job that is a really scary fact and it's
scary because as women become more more
educated as women are occupying the
lion's share of the seats in
post-secondary institutions across North
America and elsewhere me what's
happening to us what is happening to us
that we think that we have to numb and
vacate with alcohol why is this it's
more than just celebration something is
going really wrong and the markets there
to service so that feminized drinking
culture is alive and well and I just
want to put up my hand and say let's
have a hard look at what's going on and
and know your personal vulnerabilities I
should have known with two alcoholic
parents that I was pretty vulnerable no
you know whether you're vulnerable to
breast cancer you should really know
what you're putting down your throat in
and take a hard look at just like with
everything else are you safe are you
healthy is it okay for you if it is
wonderful good I do like the the bottle
print well I think that this kind of
brings us to a conclusion but I just
wanted to say thank you that I did enjoy
you know having this conversation with
you I think that you bring up a very I
guess alarming issue that really does
not get to the table very much except I
know within the the profession that I've
worked in in this field it's always
there but to the general public it's not
there of having that conversation and I
think being able to have it from from
one professional to another but also at
the community level as well too